hello good morning
lovely people thank you for joining me
today
for from wcf to grpc
um i can see lots
of letters and one person
who's obviously got a green screen
and is wearing entirely green and has
painted themselves green
and is just generally quite green
so yes my name is
mark grendel um i am currently working
at uh visual recode
or on visual recode with gibraltar
software
[Music]
and there's somebody they've turned
their camera on
um it's actually it's really nice for
presenters
um or certainly for me if people
are sort of somewhere sensible and
private and
they have clothes on for them to
uh for people to turn their cameras on
so i can see some faces
so when i say something hilarious there
you go peter thank you very much
um when i say something hilarious i can
see you rolling on the floor laughing
um so yeah i really appreciate that
thank you very much guys
so much better than talking to a screen
full of letters
okay right yes um
so you are all here because you
are wcf survivors i'm guessing
um or possibly you're even wcf
fans and you love wcf and it's done
wonderful things for you and you've
built amazing things with it
and you want to know what the situation
is
and what happens next
which is the eternal question of
software development
and so as dot net developers
we are now looking to the future of
net we had microsoft build last month
and they shared a lot of the plans for
net 5
and everything there and you may have
been at microsoft build
last year 2019 or you may have watched
it online
and you will have seen the announcement
they made there
so we are currently on net core
3.1 which is a long term service release
and then this november uh we're not
getting.net core four we're getting.net
five
and everything's coming together and
xamarin and mono
and winrt and all the things
are coming together into dot net five
and then next year they'll be dot net
six which gives us another lts release
and then so on every year at new.net
and the even numbered ones will be
long-term service releases
and looking back um at
the nets of the past
nets of history um net four
is no longer and there are certain bits
of
net four that are not coming across
to net five and are going to stay
they'll continue to be supported but
um they're not coming over to dot net
core for various reasons
so um web forms for example
the old classic from 2001 asp.net web
forms
is not coming to net 5 because
a lot of web forms was too closely
linked to
windows and to iis
and also in the modern world
just looks like not quite such a good
idea
and so microsoft saying if you have web
forms code
you should just migrate it to blazer
which is not something i would
want to have to try and do
but it's it's difficult
web forms and blazer are completely
different technologies
nothing in common whatsoever so what
they're basically saying there is
just rewrite it rewrite your code in
this nice
shiny new thing we've built and wcf
wcf is not coming to net5 and we'll talk
a little bit more about why that
is in a moment and what microsoft said
at build 2019
was if you have wcf applications then we
recommend migrating them to
grpc which is now in net core 3.1
and will continue to be supported going
forward in
net 5 and workflow foundation
i never used workflow foundation and i
never really thought workflow foundation
was particularly popular but when i've
done this in talks and said
hands up if you use workflow foundation
there's always quite a few hands that go
up
and and it surprises me so that
workflow foundation there is actually an
open source port of workflow foundation
taking that over to uh net core and dot
net five
uh so that people can continue to use
that
and there is an open source port of wcf
as well
but again we will talk about that in a
moment
so i'm going to talk to you today about
how you can
rescue your wcf investment and
some tricks and things you can use to
migrate your existing code to wcf
and also how grpc as a platform
and as a.net core technology compares
to windows communication foundation
so wcf was created
in uh 2006. it was part of the whole
windows vista is going to change the
world and dotnet 3 is going to change
the world
thing which went so very very well
and we all have happy happy memories of
those days
windows presentation foundation windows
communication foundation
and windows workflow foundation which
then
just had to be changed to workflow
foundation because the world wildlife
fund threatened to sue microsoft
and that's it's a bad look getting sued
by a panda
people tend to take the pandas aside
when that happens and so microsoft
backed down
despite their fantastic lawyers um
but wcf was uh the dream
it was creating networked applications
service oriented architecture was all
the thing at the time
and we wanted to build systems that were
spread across
dozens or hundreds of machines and
communicate between them using
networking and wcf
let you do that but without having to
write all the networking code into your
controllers or into your
your services themselves you just wrote
your services and then
you wrote a couple of lines of very
simple xml
to configure those services and
tell the system how they should be
communicating with each other
and for example wcf
you could make wcf communicate using
soap over
http and so you could have a
net server talking to java clients or
python clients
and those were the only three
programming languages in the world
in 2006 and you could have those
services communicating
over http uh with the messages formatted
as
soap and you could have java servers
written in some other language talking
so
and you could generate.net clients to
talk to your java servers it was all
completely brilliant
um and and there was much rejoicing
uh and then the other option uh i mean
there were many many options
and if you've used wcf you'll know there
were many options for
formatting messages and for passing
those messages between servers and
clients but the other main one that
people used
was net tcp and net tcp
actually for its time net tcp was
phenomenal
it used a binary message format um it
used raw tcp
sockets and it just it was incredibly
fast it could do
two-way communication so
the client could call methods on the
server
and the server could call methods on the
client with callback interfaces and
everything
and it really was very very clever stuff
net tcp
uh even today is it's really very
impressive the problem with net tcp
was that it was a proprietary.net
technology which meant that it was a net
wcf
server talking to a wcf client
and you lost all of the interop so your
entire distributed system
had to be written in one language
or potentially two languages some of it
could be written in c sharp some of it
could be written in vb.net
but it all had to be written in net and
in my experience
over the last 15 years what this is
actually meant is that people said my
entire distributive system must be
contained
in a single.net solution in source
control
and i will build it all in one go and
deploy it
all at the same time every time and so
that's not really a distributed system
that's just a monolith
with socket and
to make the magic of wcf work
you needed to configure the binding of
your wcf application
in in xml and
uh however this may have started off if
anyone has run
any services of any complexity in
production
you will know that your xml
configuration for that service
generally ends up actually being longer
than the service code itself
you end up with thousands of lines of
xml
with no intellisense and no code
completion
and no compilation step and the only way
to figure out whether your xml is
working
is to try and run your system in
production and then when it doesn't
you can say ah what is wrong with my xml
so yes
so now after 15 years of building
some really quite large and impressive
and and complicated systems with wcf
uh microsoft have come along and they've
said to us no more wcf
we are now saying you should use grpc
and i think it's worth stopping for a
moment to talk about
why they are um
saying this why they are promoting grpc
and why they are not putting in the
effort
to bring wcf into the.net core and
dotnet 5 era
the thing is that
soap so the thing that made wcf cross
platform soap xml messages and we'll
just look at one of these
uh just go look at the configuration
a soap xml message is enormous
if you want to send the value 42
over soap then you need to declare a
model
object some xml schema
that actually puts um 42 into xml so
that either needs to be as a value of
element or an attribute of an element
and then you need to wrap that element
in some
soap so say this is a soap message with
the value 42 in it
and then when you want to send that
across the wire you need to wrap it in
another soap envelope that says this is
the value 42 and this is the message
that i would like to send the value 42
to here are some headers that go along
with
value 42 that's necessary for the next
server to process this message correctly
and then when the server sends the
uh question mark answer back again
i forgot to share my screen
i completely forgot to share my screen
there's my screen
right hey look excellent
right so yes this is
here here is my lovely slide for wcf
with soap over http so we've got
net and java and python in the corners
there and here was my lovely slide for
wcf with net tcp
and so we've got
we've got wcf and wcf and wcf and wcf
in the corners there and um and then
here's my lovely slide for the
uh oh so simple xml that you use to
configure your bindings and
contracts and services and service
behaviors um and everything else
um and uh yes
um hands up if you loved
uh wcf configuration
um and then this is this is the slide
that we were on
so yeah um soap is enormous and in
2006 soap seemed like a good idea
because in 2006
xml seemed like a good idea and
everybody was using xml for everything
and nobody could ever come up with
anything better than xml and so
it made perfect sense um and
uh net tcp well
that microsoft actually published the
all the specifications for net tcp both
for the wire formats
and for the actual communication
protocol
and said to people like sun microsystems
and other platforms hey here are the
specs for net tcp
you could get your language talking to
our services open at tcp and the
whole of the rest of the ecosystem went
no and
and ignored microsoft
and so it's it's carried on like that
and in pure microsoft shops it's
it's continued to work but since that
time
google have released grpc
and grpc actually grew out of
an internal um project and standard
at google called stubby and stubby was
what mike
google were using for communication
between all their internal services
and some of those services were written
in python and some of those services
were written in java
and some of them were written in c plus
plus
and stubby was very much like net tcp
but google had already had an interest
in making it work between
multiple languages because they were
using multiple languages
um and so protobuf was
public they had shared protobuf and
protobuf
uh provided data serialization and it
was language neutral and it was platform
neutral and it was extensible
and it was small and fast and simple um
and they had published the specification
for protobuf but
um they also maintained it as an open
source project
which meant people were more likely to
engage with it and
they wrote code generation layers for
it for other languages as well
including.net
and so protobuf was similar to the wire
format
from net tcp but it was open source
and everybody could see it and of course
it was google and
google as everybody knows aren't evil
no they're not shush um
and so internally they were using stubby
as their
communication library and stubby
sent photograph messages over tcp
sockets so in that sense it was a bit
like net tcp
but then http 2 came along
and http 2 could do all the things
that stubby needed it could do um
it could maintain open connections it
could send binary data it could compress
headers
it could do streaming it could do
two-way streaming
and so when http2
arrived which itself was based on
technology that had come out of google
in the
spdy protocol
google said hey http 2 actually does all
the things
that we've got custom code to do in
stubby let's
rewrite stubby as an http 2
thing and so they did and
um and then that meant it was more
widely applicable and
simpler and people could use it more
widely and so they open sourced that and
called it grpc
and so grpc provides remote procedure
calls
um it's language neutral it's platform
neutral it's extensible
it's small and fast and on the
uh from the user's side
at least from the person creating the
grpc application
it is simple um going into the actual
source code for grpc it's a little bit
more complicated
so grpc gives us the combination
of net tcp performance and
soap interoperability and
microsoft had a choice between
bringing wcf up to net core and trying
to make it
match grpc in terms of both net tcp
performance and
soap interoperability or
bringing wcf to.net core and just
letting it continue bwcf
and only be fast when talking
between.net systems
and only be interoperable when using
soap which is really
totally dead in the water at this point
or they could just say hey
let's let's adopt grpc
and if we adopt grpc then we will be
able to enter the
ecosystem which currently supports
um net java go c plus plus objective c
swift node.js python rupee dot php pearl
rust haskell scala kotlin elixir and
erlang
and even web browsers
with a little caveat around the web
browser bits and pieces
and so that's the decision they made and
they built first class support the grpc
into asp.net core and netcore 3.1
and just suggested to people that they
migrate their code across
and i'm here to show you that that's not
actually too complicated
so
you can actually already do grpc in
in.net
you can do and grpc.net 4.5
google have been supporting.net
for a long time with both protobuf and
grpc
but the net 4.5 implementation is
actually a wrapper around
the native grpc server
that's written in c and c plus plus
and microsoft it works but
microsoft wanted to make it a
first-class way of doing services
in asp.net core and so they created
asp.net called grpc
but they didn't create it as net
slash asp.net grpc
or anything like that they went to the
grpc project
and they said hey we'd like to do our
own
um re-implementation of
grpc that sits really nicely in asp.net
core
and we would like to contribute that
into the grpc project
and so asp.net core grpc lives in the
grpc organization on github
and is managed by
grpc project members
and so it's part of the grpc ecosystem
not
just part of the asp.net core ecosystem
an asp.net core grpc is a fully managed
implementation
um it's maintained by microsoft
developers including
james newton king who did a talk about
it yesterday morning
and who i think basically if he never
sees another jason serializer again for
as long as he lives he'll be happy
and so he's um he's now working on
asp.net core grpc and it runs on the
kestrel http server
and the clients for it
in.net use system.net.http client
and all these facts the fact that it
runs on kestrel http server
for example means that when you have
your
startup code with your grpc application
it looks just like a normal asp.net core
startup application and we have a
services.ad
grpc method um
and we have within our configure point
we have
endpoints.map grpc service
and it looks exactly
like a traditional asp.net core
application because you know it's been
around for three or four years now
we can have traditional asb net core
applications
it's it's practically historical um
so if you've never seen a grpc
application before
um we can talk about what it looks like
and how it is different from a wcf
application
so grpc applications have a dot proto
file
and that is the interface definition so
in wcf
when you created a service you would
declare an interface
and decorate it as a service contract
and you would say hey this is what my
service is going to look like
it's going to have these methods they're
going to take these parameters
they're going to use these objects to
send data backwards and forwards
and this is this is my
this is what my service is going to look
like and then you would
create an implementation of that c sharp
interface
and you would write all the code that
made those actual endpoints and
everything else work
so you had this separation of the
definition of your interface
and the definition of your actual
service um
and grpc works in a very very similar
way
except it's across it was built from the
ground up to be cross-platform
and so the interface definition
doesn't happen in any particular
language it happens
in a a separate language just for doing
that
and then your service implementation can
be written in whichever language you
like
so this is a proto file with some
services
and this is uh the protobuf
interface definition language and here
we are
saying this is our syntax this is our
package is called portfolio service
our service is called portfolios
and it has two methods
get which takes a get request and
returns get response and get all which
so this is what would be our
interface our service contract interface
in a wcf application
and then our messages
look like this and this is what would be
our data contracts
in awcf application and
that we keep it completely separate uh
this is a separate language
and in these messages you can see we've
got
a data type and a field name and the
field names are actually wrong in this
screen grab those should be um lowercase
underscore
format for our field names um
to be properly cross-platform um
and then on the end there we have a
field number and the field number is a
very useful thing
um one of the issues with sort of api
development and
distributed system development is
versioning of
systems and if you
change a field type or
add a field name or remove a field
then you have a chance of breaking
um any existing clients out there
or potentially even having a client
that's got a newer version of the client
code
talking to a server that's still running
an older version of the server
protobuf uses the field numbers as part
of the encoding of the message
over the wire to keep things nice and
small um but it also means that
uh if you add a new field and take an
old field out
as long as you don't reuse the field
number you get some level of uh
compatibility between the messages um
and so if in portfolio item i sort of
removed cost
as a double and added price as a float
um then if i made prices field number
five
then uh i wouldn't be causing
um breakage of my contract there
and we have a set of types in protobuf
which are available across all the
different platforms
and then we can construct more
complicated types just by creating
our own messages and
for arrays or lists we have this
repeated keyword here
which says to the protobuf generator
create a list
okay so that's a prototype file and
we'll look at those
in a bit more detail shortly and the way
protobuf works
is that in whichever platform you are
working it generates a base
class or certainly in
languages where that makes sense it
generates a base class which you can
inherit from
and so that code that protobuf file
there
in asp.net or grpc
will generate a portfolio's base class
and that base class declares
virtual versions of all the methods so
we have a virtual get method that we can
override
it's important to note that it's not an
abstract method it is actually a virtual
method
if you don't override the method there
is a default implementation
that will just effectively throw grpc's
equivalent of a not implemented
exception
so the call won't fail exactly
but it will throw an exception
and you can see in this code sample here
that we have
a rpc exception and these
work like fault exceptions in wcf so you
can
throw an exception on the server and you
can catch that exception on the client
and any information inside that
exception will be passed across
at the moment it doesn't support so
fault exception in wcf is a generic type
and you can pass a whole object over
with it
it's technically possible to do that in
grpc but it's not supported
in the net version of grpc
yet it will be at some point in the
future so
yes rather than declaring interface and
implementing it
we have our protobuf file
with our service definition and our
message definitions
and we use those to generate the
relevant classes
in our net application
and this is completely integrated with
the ms build process
there's a grpc.tools package which has
uh build targets which build these
files build these base classes just as
part of the build
if you're working in visual studio um
they'll actually just
run every time you save the proto file
it'll run
and update the code for you if you
if you're running from a visual studio
code or vs mac
or jetbrains rider you
occasionally have to do a sort of manual
build
to get things to update
okay so
grpc modes
wcf had a lot of modes a lot of
different bindings
and contracts and service behaviors and
everything else
which is one of the reasons that people
liked it so much and people want to be
able to do full duplex and
and all these sorts of things and grpc
can match most of those things
so wcf obviously the simplest one was
with basic http binding
and you would just have a request and
that would send the result
and then send another request and that
would send another result
and so grpc has exactly the same thing
you have a call
that takes some parameters and returns
a parameter a response
value which is very straightforward
wcf if you were using the right bindings
with the right service behaviors
and you returned an i innumerable of t
from your wcf method then
it would actually send the results one
at a time so it would send the first
result
before the enumerator had finished on
the server side
and so you could stream results from the
server to the client
and grpc provides this with server
streaming
and streaming support is built into http
2 and so the grpc is just taking
advantage of that
wcf also had one way to server
which was effectively void methods on
your service contract
and the client would say hey i'm just
going to call that method
and i'm not even going to wait for an
answer i'm just telling you something
i don't care what you think of it don't
ask me back
and grpc supports client streaming
so the client can open a stream to the
server
and then just send messages over that
stream
very quickly without needing to wait for
a response
and then of course wcf had full duplex
which worked with either net tcp
or with ws dual http binding
where the client could send messages to
the server
or the client could call methods on the
server and the server could call methods
on the client
via a callback interface entirely
independently of each other
so they didn't have to wait for the
other one to ask
before being able to trigger behavior on
the other side
and grpc can do bi-directional streaming
and send messages um
out of order to each other um
in the same way which allows us to
implement something
similar to wcf's full duplex binding
it just works in a very different way
and of course wcf also supported
asynchronous over cube so you could bind
wcf
to msmq and grpc
doesn't have any equivalent to that
because the grpc doesn't have a
queuing technology built into its
operating system that it would really
like to tie you into using
so let's look at some sample code let's
look at a request
response application um and
look at how we would convert this to wcf
so i'm going to make this a little bit
bigger
so here we have a wcf service
we've got our i hotel service contract
here
and this has got four operation
contracts
we've got get available rooms that
returns a
list of rooms and takes a check-in
date and a check out date which is date
time offset
we have a get room which returns
a single room we have a get rooms with
the
room numbers takes an array of numbers
and
returns an array of rooms and we finally
have
an all rooms um operation
which returns an i innumerable of room
which would
therefore
stream those to the client if we
called that correctly and we have our
hotel.data
project here and we have our data
contract which has got
room and we've got four properties
we've got a decimal property here and we
have
our data members within our
code here and so it's it's very very
simple
um and so we just need to figure out
to convert this oh and then of course we
have our
hotel service implementation which isn't
decorated with any code
particularly it's just the
implementation of that
interface okay
so to convert this to migrate this
project to grpc we need to create a
proto file
that is the equivalent or contains the
equivalent
of this service contract
and contains the equivalent of this
data contract and then we need to
migrate the implementation code across
to our net core application
and hook all that up so actually
as long as our net for
code isn't using anything that is uh not
entirely incompatible with net core
we should be okay which is not
in this instance but
um we're not using things like operation
context we're not using um
a lot of the sort of complicated in code
features of wcf
we're not using any non-net core apis
we're not using entity framework five
point something so
so we should be okay to move this across
to dot net core
and here is
the equivalent of that
application as an asp.net core
project so this you can create a grpc
project in
asp.net core either from visual studio's
new projects thing
or from the command line you can just
say dotnet new grpc
and that will create you a project that
looks something like this
so your program cs file looks
like a regular one your startup file
here
we have service.grpc
and we have our mac grpc service here
just talking to
services.hotel service and
we can just we can copy our ihotel
service
interface over that works exactly the
same we don't have the service contract
type in.net call we don't have the
system.runtime
dot service model assembly available
anymore so
we'll just comment out our service
contract
and operation contract
attributes on there but our hotel
service we can literally just
copy and paste this across um this is
fine
nothing in there that doesn't work um
and our hotel.data
again we can just copy our room class
across this is still
fine um and we'll just comment out our
data contract and data member attributes
because those aren't going to work
anymore
and then we just need to hook these in
to our
grpc application we're looking at
hotel service actually i mean we've got
an interface
and we've got an implementation of that
interface so
we could just hook those up with
dependency injection
in the configure services method of our
startup class
and so now we have our our old what used
to be our wcf hotel service
um is is hooked up independency
injection and i can just
get that injected into my grpc service
okay so let's take a look at our proto
that we need to create here
so here's my
proto file that i have constructed
to replace my service contract
interface but i have a get available
rooms
takes a get available rooms request and
returns a get available rooms response
um my get room takes a get room request
you can see a sort of pattern emerging
here and i'll talk about why
i use that pattern in a moment um the
all rooms so this is the method that was
returning an eye innumerable
that's going to return a stream of all
rooms response
so that will then enable server
streaming and allow the rooms to just be
sent
over a stream one at a time
so each of these rpc methods declared
here
takes a single parameter and returns
a single type and
that is a hard and fast rule rpc
methods in protobuf cannot take more
than one parameter
and so we always use a message object
a message for each parameter and a
message for each response
and the reason for this is
the same as the reason that
microsoft have just added default
interface implementations in c
sharp 8. if you change the number of
parameters
that a method takes then you've broken
um backward and forward compatibility
with that method
but if a method takes an object
and you change the shape of that object
you haven't necessarily
broken the contract of the method and so
your service will still work with older
clients
as long as you remember to check the
message that's been sent
and see that the fields that you want
are set
correctly or that you can work things
out from that
so a get available rooms request is
taking two parameters check-in date and
check-out date
and funnily enough protobuf has no
built-in date type
but because date is a compound type
it actually made more sense to
implement it as a message type in itself
and so
google have a bunch of
standard dot proto files that are built
into the compiler
um and timestamp is one of those uh
the other one that i use a lot is
date is uh duration which matches the
time span
um but there are lots of others in there
as well there are
we have sort of in 32 and
string and so the
the built-in scalar types in grpc
we have string we have bytes we have
boolean we have float
and we have double and then we have 10
different types of integer
um so we've got n6 in 32 and in 64
and there are five types of each of
those and it's all to do with
how the encoding is handled so
if you know your ins are going to be big
numbers
then it's more efficient to just use
four bytes every time so there's a fixed
32 that uses that
if you know that your integer is likely
to have as many negative values as
positive values
then there is an s int um
which is more efficient
for values that are on both sides of
zero
um then there's int then there's uint
which is for obviously
values that are always higher than zero
so yes
um lots to do with the ends and then
everything else is in what they call the
well-known types
and the other thing that's in there is
there's a
an int 32 value type inside
google.protobuf which and
for all the built-in scalar types
there's a
thing value type which in c-sharp
comes out as nullable so if you want a
nullable hint here
um you would use
int google.protobuff. value but that
won't work at the moment because i
haven't included the wrappers
proto okay
and then in my services once i create
that
i will get my um
my service base class being generated
here
and i can just inject my service
contract
type into here to do my
coding to bring my old
wcf code in and so let's take a look
at the implementation of one of these
methods
here let's take a look at the um get
available rooms response
let's start by looking at get room
because this is the simplest one
and i don't know why it's not at the top
so get room
every of every one of our grpc methods
the definition is
created for us and so this is just a
simple request response
and so it just takes an instance of the
request message and returns
using task an instance of the response
message
and every method also gets this server
call context
so our
class service base doesn't it's not like
the controller class it doesn't create a
context or a user
or any view methods or anything like
that so everything we need comes through
on the context parameter and this
actually has
no intellisense available at the moment
but
in asp.net core grpc that context
wraps around the http context and it has
a get http context
method which will return the current
http context and then you can get the
user
if you've got um authentication enabled
um you can set headers you can read
headers off the request you can write
headers the response
um and you can do all this sort of stuff
through the context here and so we
literally
um we're just going to
uh call our service contract and say hey
give me this room so this is giving us
the data contract version
of room and then we can just return that
get room response
and pass that across as the value
because in our protos
folder here to make life easier
we created some extensions
to the protobuf room message type
so protobuf the protobuf compiler
declares
all the classes that it generates as
partial
and that means we can add whatever we
want to them
we don't have to inherit from it we can
just add new things to it and that means
that one of the things we can add
is implicit operators and so we can
create
implicit operators that magically cast
our protobuf room
message type to our old
what used to be our wcf data contract
type
and you can see here that we're saying
either way
number is number and price we'll just
convert that to a double
so grpc doesn't support decimals
natively
um and that's okay as long as you
only use the protobuf objects
for passing data from one side
to the other you'll never lose any
accuracy on a double
by serializing it over protobuf
the only time you lose accuracy is if
you then use the protobuf object itself
to do maths for example if you try and
multiply 4.99 by
5.0 then
you will be told that the answer is
24.9888894
it is possible to do decimals you just
need to create your own decimal proto
um with units and nanos and it's very
straightforward
and i blogged about it on the visual
recode website
so we can now just pass this thing
around
um we can pass our
room that we got from our service
contract we can just pass it back
over our get room response here you can
see that i get room response just as a
room
value is one now i could just
return room from this because that's all
that's going at the moment
but a good
idea um i i may even go so far to say
it's a best practice
to return a specific response type
from each of your
messages
just in case at some point you decide
that what get room returns
in its room response that might have a
lot more information
and you might decide so that might
return sort of room details
like um who's assigned to cleaning that
room and
um who stayed in it last and all this
sort of thing
whereas get rooms which returns a list
of rooms might return less information
and so rather than returning data
objects directly
i prefer to return these response
messages
which means i can change them so i just
here is my response and the value on
that response is a room
and if i wanted to add more things to
that response i could do that quite
easily
um so get available rooms
is a little bit more complicated get
available rooms
um
response here has a repeated
room values so this is going to be my
list of rooms here
so i create a new get available rooms
response
and then i can't actually set this
values property that's read only
property
so i'm just going to add values to it
from the service contract here
also remember the service contract
the request message
has check-in date and check-out date and
you can see here
that check-in date so these have
underscores in their name and the reason
they have underscores
is because um the code gen for
all the different languages will turn
that into whatever makes the most sense
for that particular language
so the python code gen will just leave
it as check-in date
the java code gen will change it to
camelcase where the first character's
lowercase and
each word is uppercase the c-sharp
version
as you can see here has converted it to
pascal case
where the first letter of each word is
uppercase and
if you want to do that yes the code
samples will be available on git
um and i will link those
um in the chat room at the end of the
talk um so yes
it's easier to do that case shifting if
you use the
all lower case and underscore
form in the first place
okay so let's go
and look at um
get the all rooms code here
so here's our get rooms where we have uh
a request.numbers
and we're just going to convert so this
is um
in grpc this is a repeated field
type which is a generic type very
similar to a list
so we're going to say create an array
populate that array from the repeated
field instance
which
we can uh we can see here then pass that
across to our old service contract
then create our response and get our
values and add our response values
into there and then return that back and
then we have all rooms
and this in our wcf service was the one
that returned
um and i enumerable
and so here we can see how a streaming
service works
we get our all rooms request and rather
than us returning a stream
and having to worry about how do you
create a stream and how do you set it up
properly and all this sort of thing
um the grpc framework has already
generated all the code to do that and so
it just passes the response stream
in for us and so all we have to do
is write our responses to it one at a
time
and so this allows us to create
streaming services
really incredibly easily
and you just drop into slack here
it's such a nice chat i wasn't even
missing the presentation at all
anything to do with certificates
anything to do with encoding in wcf
configuration
yes absolutely and now this runs over
http 2
um so certificates is just tls
certificates attached to
http 2 kestrel and anything like that
anything to do with encoding it's just
protobuf so you don't have to worry
about that at all
and wcf configuration again there is
it it's grpc it's not saying hey you can
do this and you can do that and they
work this way and that way
actually if you dig into it after a
couple of years you'll find that you can
configure the hell out of grpc and
protobuf
but there's really no reason why you
would so
um okay so that's request response
that's really quite straightforward
um we also have server streaming which
we saw
from that last method there that was
just what used to be an eye innumerable
and now we have an eye response stream
when we write things asynchronously to
it
um but there is also bidirectional
streaming
which is the equivalent of a full duplex
and also wcf supported
session so you could say session mode
required and when the client started
talking to the server
the server would create an instance of
the service contract class
and then that would actually be held
on the heap permanently and any local
fields it had that
that stored state would stay around and
all the
communication from that client would go
to that particular instance of that
class
i mean you know no load balancing or
anything like that
and we can achieve that using
bidirectional streaming
and so i'm going to
use for this the example of the
calculator
that microsoft used in all their wcf
samples
so the calculator is a duplex
service and
here is the equivalent protobuf file
so we have a calculator
that takes a stream of calculator
actions and returns a stream of
calculator callbacks
the wcf service took an i calculated
callback interface which had
a right value and an equation method
i think i
my computer died i'm doing this off my
laptop and i don't seem to be able to
find
the original wcf implementation of this
but it's not the important thing
so we have a clear action and an add to
action and a subtract from action
multiplied by
we have a result callback and an
equation call back
and we can use another feature of
um
protobuf here so protobuf provides
something like a discriminated union
you can use this one-off keyword on
a message to say here are
fields one two three four five only one
of these can be set
at a time and so if you set the clear
field to something it will unset any of
the other fields that may have been set
so we can guarantee that um this action
will only represent one of these things
so like an enum or a discriminated union
in sharp or thing
is there a tool to generate the
protofile i love that question
i will be answering it at the end of the
talk
um
so our and
which is very soon damn
um so yes uh our code for this
basically looks like this
and so here we have
our run method and we just
we've injected our old calculator
contract
in here and we
read all the messages off here and we
invoke
messages on our old contract um
based on the action so action was that
thing that's the one-off field
and we can do a switch statement to see
which one of them is set and
then we can call things back and so
forth and there's all sorts of
complicated plumbing code in here
that makes our old wcf callback and
everything code work
with our newer um grpc
code and all this code will go up onto
github
at the end of this thing at the end of
this talk which is in one minute and
they get much more stressed about it
security it supports asp net core
security asp net authentication and
certificate security
um and uh
you it don't won't do windows
authentication so you need to use tokens
um that you get from windows
authentication and pass them using
asp.net authentication
in production you can run this in docker
kubernetes and
service use service meshes and
everything else and i will point you to
some
example code for that i wrote a whole
book about this
called grpc for wcf developers which is
on microsoft's
architecture portal on their
docs.microsoft.com um that was
written with my wife who can write and
i can do grpc so between us we made a
book
um and uh we were pretty pleased with
how that turned out
and then as far as tools go i have been
working very very
hard on building visual recode which
will actually
take your wcf application and generate
an asp.net core grpc application
including duplex and session um and
we've got version coming up we'll take
uh old wcf rest and convert that to an
asp.net core mvc application
we're building on that um it's very
reasonably priced
um if you've got like more than one wcf
service it's probably worth
taking a look at because it will save
you just the hours of typing
proto files and everything else it
doesn't do the whole thing it's not 100
guaranteed
but it will save you time and yes
it isn't it isn't open source i charge
money for it
we support it um and we will help you
with your project
and so i'm uh yeah it's it's a thing
okay um i hope that was helpful i will
put more information into the
slack channel now enjoy the rest of your
day and thanks very much for listening
to me
cheers bye